[Music]
i want to switch a little bit and talk a
little bit a little bit about the the
sort of systematic approach and
you know you being
a big part of shark tank and going
through
a large amount of of different pitches
and different businesses looking at uh
the numbers and is there any specific uh
list of processes or things that you
look for specifically
before you decide to invest into startup
or an idea and and what these things are
yes there is
um
this is getting more important every
year
more and if you'd looked at a company a
mix of shark tank companies or any
consumer goods or services companies
before the pandemic the global pandemic
and you split you know revenue or income
into a pie chart here's the different
channels it would have come from 50
percent would have come from retail at
50 cents on the dollar and so retail
distribution prior to the pandemic was
the way most consumer goods and services
companies provided their product to
customers all around the world
40 percent would have come from amazon
which is basically a large retailer but
that's not 50 cents on the dollar margin
amazon is 60 cents on the dollar margin
so slightly better however amazon as
you're well aware does not give up its
customer data so you have no idea who
you're selling to amazon keeps that
information for themselves and has made
them highly competitive because they
analyze that data in a way that you
can't or couldn't before and prior to
the pandemic 10 percent of revenue was
coming from the company's own website
direct to their consumer generally
they'd set up on a shopify or something
else and work with facebook geo locked
advertising that worked for them all
around the world as well
now that is a 80 to 85 gross margin
business when you sell direct to
consumer however most of them were not
making money on that channel part of the
pandemic
because they had really high customer
acquisition costs that's a long answer
your question but the point is
customer acquisition costs today when
most businesses have gone 50 direct to
consumer is the whole business you have
to understand how to acquire a customer
and have its value be less than the cost
of acquiring it in other words if your
customer acquisition cost is more than
lifetime value of of the customer you're
going to lose a lot of money that's
going to be a bad outcome so you've got
to figure out how to do this
successfully and i think at the end of
the day
that's the the most important thing that
i look at on any shark tank dealer any
deal
i ask you what does it cost you acquire
customer and you tell me five dollars
let's say and i say what's the lifetime
value of the customer 25
i'm ready to pour millions onto that
business model because that's just
pouring gasoline on the fire all we're
going to do is acquire more customers
gain scale get more market share but
that's not
the case in in many companies they don't
know what it costs to acquire a customer
and i avoid
investing in those ones
i like the like the answer i think that
you i think i understand why you're
getting into the nfd space now
right it's not numbers game for sure
yeah and and also uh you know kevin just
pointed out the exact numbers of
what my chocolate business does so kevin
i own a chocolate factory over here and
and it all started with a social
uh
kind of what we talked about earlier
about having a mission a good mission
and it was to support the farmers
because in a uh any food related
business it's not me who has the highest
risk it's the farmers who has the
highest risk and especially in the cacao
industry in the chocolate industry
now
what i felt running the company one
thing was
yes i'm doing right it i can go to bed
knowing that i'm doing something right
every day
but
especially here in asia
right now what has happened i feel is it
kind of become it has become like a
fashion to say this thing but not
actually
doing stuff
right and and not necessarily as a
business owner has translated for me for
sales there are other mediums that helps
me get the same
what do you think is that about like is
it kind of like going into a fashion
nowadays or
you know much of an industry inside and
or actually people are actually doing
stuff
when you look at the market
so the way a mission is communicated to
a customer is through social media and
this is the risk of it for people as you
said some companies decide that they
want to be fashionable and they come up
with some sustainability idea or some
give back strategy which is complete
marketing and
bs essentially and
people have become very hip
to [ __ ] out there they know when
they're being lied to they know when
it's a scam they know when it's not
honest and they take
swift action against companies that try
to do that if you really have a
sustainability mandate if you really do
give back to farmers if you're really
doing that show examples of it on social
media that people can connect with
because that's how they connect with
your products and services every single
one of my successful companies has the
four positions i talked about earlier
able to communicate
able to explain why they can execute
they know their numbers and their social
missions are communicated through very
strong social media and particularly in
asia the platforms that work better
there are not the same ones that work in
switzerland that work in the united
states you really need to understand how
you can attract your customer to to meet
you and keep that daily dialogue open on
social what i learned was so interesting
about the companies that were successful
is during the pandemic they told their
struggle stories online every day they
would do a 59 second video and talk
about what was going right and what was
going wrong with their business and
their customers got more engaged with
them and became even stronger supporters
and bought more product from them during
the pandemic because first of all in
many cases they were sequestered at home
and secondly they wanted their companies
to be successful that direct connection
so you know that mission whatever that
statement is with examples online and
well well shown on the different
platforms and and i must say this about
social it's our number one spend across
all our portfolios now but the skill set
needed to publish on linkedin is
different than tick tock is different
than twitter is different than facebook
is different than instagram and now we
have separate
managers on each different vertical
because we've learned that one skill set
does not translate to another in terms
of managing the algorithm changes that
occur every day and sometimes twice a
day to understand what's working and
what isn't in communicating with our
customers
so important
that's very insightful and special for
me you know i was communicating that for
a long time and sales didn't pick up and
i guess that's that has more to do with
the asian
uh thing uh of like you know going with
the trend and and and not actually who's
doing right but that's a whole another
story kevin how much do you value
you know in the world where networking
your communication skills and you know
your
how great of a storyteller you are
um
which plays an important role where do
you see a college degree fit in all of
this do you think it's still as
important as it was
5 10 15 years ago that's a great
question that is a great question and
uh very insightful of you to ask that
because you know i spend a fair amount
of my time teaching graduating cohorts
of engineers uh mit harvard waterloo
mcgill
temple um notre dame and i meet um these
you know the reason i do engineering
cohorts is a third of every engineering
class regardless of what discipline it
is electrical computer science whatever
they're going to start their own
companies and i selfishly want to meet
them first before they start talking to
the venture capitalists but if the
information is the same
you know
the thing about a college degree
it's not
what you learn there in your classes
that ends up being valuable to you it's
the people you meet
because in your career you're going to
run into these people your whole life
and they're going to go and disperse
into different disciplines and different
companies and banking and whatever else
it is
and you will draw on them as a resource
as they will on you in your career
because you know each other you can't
make new old friends that's not possible
to do so what i found in my own life is
you know my mba for example i spent two
years getting
you know masters of business degree
i don't remember a single thing in those
classes i have no idea what they taught
me there but
the people that i met there are now some
of my most important business contacts
and bankers and associates all around
the world because they've scattered you
know from shanghai to hong kong to phnom
penh cambodia to julia switzerland and i
do business everywhere and and there are
my contacts there and some of them have
gone into politics very powerful allies
in the u.s senate and you know it's it's
all
about those relationships and so i would
argue that a college degree whether
you're going to burn through one year or
two years or
you know four years doing it has
tremendous value but pick a discipline
where you can actually make money you
know it it's unless you're already
successful financially you're gonna have
to pay back 80 to 100 000 or 80 to 100
000 swiss francs or whatever it is
you're going
and so
you you have to understand that this is
an investment in yourself
and then you should think a little bit
about what you want to do
and find something you're passionate
about and invest in yourself that way
but it won't be the classes that matter
it'll be the relationships 20 years
later
absolutely i've had exactly that
experience of
graduating from from different
universities and being able to
uh test out essentially different uh
academic academic systems and and i was
studying in switzerland denmark and the
uk uh i spent when you're in the u.s as
well and and
exactly as you say it was not the
classes at all but it was the experience
that came with it and the essentially
the network that i was able to get while
i was studying or while i was doing my
internships that really made it valuable
at the end of the day
um
i'm glad you had that experience because
then it was really worth what you did
there that's terrific
absolutely and meanwhile i'm a proud
dropout
make a great team right it's a balance
right there it's a yin and yang
so now moving on to um the nft and uh
what was the thing that changed your
perception on the space or on the on the
software on the technology and
when did you kind of realize the utility
of it and what it can bring to the world
you know
in 2017 i bought my first positions in
bitcoin and ethereum
however if you recall
and i'm invested in many financial
services companies
that are regulated by the regulator in
in multiple jurisdictions
so i have to report on a quarterly basis
sometimes a monthly basis i have
internal
[Music]
compliance officers and external
auditors and i also have to file with
regulators in the geographies where we
do transactions and we own exchanges and
we
and obviously
when you have that
responsibility and particularly when
many of these companies are publicly
traded
you simply can't go offside with the
regulator that's not an option and in
2017
the regulatory environment against
crypto was toxic
they were very concerned that the
tokenization of assets that were trading
uh on you know not under regulated
regulated prospectus
particularly in the new york area that
people were trying to bring debt deals
for real estate with tokens and it was
chaos and my own compliance department
said look we we are getting signals from
our lawyers that you simply can't get
involved here because these are
unregulated securities and breaching
securities laws
that's 2017. fast forward a few years
and all of a sudden we start to see
regulators around the world in
switzerland in australia new zealand in
canada in england not the us yet
starting to open up to the idea that
there's productivity available in not
just you know
bitcoin bitcoin is one software but also
ethereum as a transactional platform and
polygon and h-bar
and helium and an
avalanche and all of these other
software projects so that for example in
canada
they were the first
to allow an etf an exchange-traded fund
be traded publicly
with the underlying asset being bitcoin
now obviously when i see that i'm
realizing things are changing and
i'm looking at our deal flow and saying
look everybody
i'm a believer and i've watched the
value of my bitcoin from 2017 it was one
of my best performing assets obviously
and ethereum
and i said look we should start to
explore a relationship with the
regulators
uh and find out what we can do in the
different
different geographies
because they're going to change their
policy at different paces right now the
most advanced on earth is canada they
have just licensed the first crypto
exchange tied to a dealer broker so
that's a company called bit by i'm very
proud to say that i'm an owner of that
we acquired the company through a public
company called wonderfuy one of my
digital assets that i've invested in
and we're also uh we've gone to
switzerland we've gone to lithuania
we're in costa rica we're talking to the
uae all of these areas are licensing new
crypto exchanges i really like the
infrastructure the internet my whole
point is what changed is the regulator
changed they have become far more
accommodative
and obviously you know i had a chance
this weekend to talk to some of the
senators here in the united states about
their policy and they're beginning to
form committees uh to start exploring uh
regulating uh stable coin like usdc
regulating bitcoin regulating ethereum
so i want to be part of that dialogue
and i'm i'm very optimistic that i will
be and i think that uh this is
finally the regulators are saying
there's too much too much value in these
platforms let's look at it
talking about regulators now
um
obviously in the nft space um
the it's a wild west it's a gold rush of
the century i i that's how i look at it
but at the same time it's a place where
people get
scammed they lose their money left and
right now that's when a kind of a
central authority is good to have
but
somehow do you feel that kind of having
a regulation is against what
crypto was actually meant for like this
um
you know
decentralized system no authority kind
of thing
how do you kind of
you know work your way around those
narratives you'd
yes i mean i
you are right there is a narrative
you're a hundred percent right the
founders of this theory and the founders
of the coding and the founders of the
first capital raised
had very much a decentralized mandate
and that's true
however let's think about it
collectively all of us that are
advocates of cryptocurrencies that have
made investments in crypto
one of my businesses
indexes for sovereign wealth funds
including where you are right now and
the middle east and the uae and and
they're the largest pools of capital in
the world
they virtually own no crypto the reason
they don't own it is that it's not
regulated and they are under mandates
their sovereign mandates or their
pension mandates to only
invest in regulated securities now
that's the other side of the equation
because if they were allowed to they
would invest typical mandate on a you
know 50 billion 100 billion dollar fund
you give an example would be uh no more
than 20 of the assets in any one sector
and there's 11 sectors in the s p and no
more than five percent of the fund in
any one name or any one company
so when i asked them how how would you
like to index for crypto currencies
if they could buy bitcoin they would put
a weighting right now on between one and
three percent of bitcoin
now when you have 100 billion dollars
under management three percent is a ton
of money so if you want to see your
bitcoin traded a quarter of a million or
half a million dollars a coin or a token
you're going to have to let these
institutions into the market they are
the incremental buyers and they don't
trade they'll buy bitcoin as an asset
and hold it in perpetuity which which
makes the the whole
environment more valuable and so the
reason you should pivot from the opinion
if you have the dogma of saying i want
to stay decentralized no regulator you
should think about that if they were to
regulate and the the biggest regulator
on earth that says policy for most
markets financial markets
is the sec in the united states since
that's why they're taking their sweet
time and going very slowly they know
what's going to happen right now those
exchanges i talked to you about in
canada and the united arab emirates only
trade two assets
bitcoin and ethereum no staking no
lending no margin they're just starting
their journey as regulators to allow to
see what happens but as time passes my
investment thesis on bitcoin and
ethereum and all the other level one
level twos that i own is
when they get regulated including usdc
which is the stable code of choice i use
for my corporation
i'm i'm limited by my own compliance
department to only have five percent in
it because they consider usdc a highly
volatile equity i don't think of it that
way but that's how it's regulated
currently so we're gonna have to get a
ruling on stable coins too but my point
is when that happens the value of all
your assets will increase geometrically
because the amount of capital that will
be willing to invest in them so that's
the balance of that argument you got to
think about
that's
really i never thought about it that way
kevin that is
like
like you know just had just exploded
that was amazing thank you so much for
that now speaking of uh i mean that's
you know when it comes to regulating
crypto it it it does uh make sense but
now speaking of nfd specifically and uh
nfds have you know they've been around
for for a while but on the on the grand
scheme of things it's it's still the
very early beginning the adoption is uh
very limited at this point uh with you
know the the most the major exchange
being open see at the moment and it's
it's somewhat too centralized uh
looking at looking at the nft space uh
what what
kind of regulation do you see in that
space on the horizon uh with your
insights into into the nfts
yes i have had a chance to talk to the
communities about this um the the
biggest question for for nfts and and
you're right there it's a very
fast-growing asset class
is whether it's a security or not
when an nft and smart contract uh has a
royalty associated with transfer of
ownership it is distributing capital and
that that generally is interpreted as
being a security no different than a
bond paying interest or a stock paying a
dividend but we haven't had a ruling on
that yet
more concerning right now is what you
said earlier that there's a lot of
scamming going on in the nft space so
it'd be much better for all of us and
i'm a huge believer in nfts
uh if we could find some way of
providing a new level of security so
that you as an owner who have made an
investment whether you've done it on a
centralized or decentralized wallet
should have some sense that there's
security and an auditable position and a
path to understand you know when
something does go awry or it's been
stolen that there is there is a way to
pursue it and we don't have that right
now so i i would say investments in much
more secure wallets and better
functioning wallets would expand the nft
space geometrically and so the the
biggest challenge that it's holding back
uh nfts in my view in terms of becoming
investable with institutions and
remember i always have my institution
hat on because that's where all the
money is it's great that you know we as
as early
investors in crypto all things crypto
including nfts are willing to to learn
and spend our time and take risks out
there but there's billions and billions
of dollars of institutional capital that
wants to go to work there too that we
have not given them the compliance
infrastructure yet
to be able to do that for example when
you buy a stock or a bond in a pension
plan you know
for a university in geneva
they immediately are able to see at the
compliance department how much you put
on whether you use leverage the position
is reported at the end of the day the
auditors can see it anytime they want
and the regulators have a report
generated that they get every quarter
every month or every week or every day
depending on the geography you're in we
have nothing like that
in anything on crypto you have to
manually do it yourself that makes you
know
regulators very nervous there's no audit
trail uh in most of these platforms and
so when i talk to institutions about
nfts they say well is there some piece
of software you have that we can attach
to our our compliance department now so
we can openly buy purchase trade nfts
the same way we do stocks and bonds that
does not exist yet now companies like
ftx are working on that
and that's why i'm associated and a
shareholder of xtx and a paid
spokesperson they had a fantastic ad on
the super bowl last night with larry
david was very funny and you know at the
end of the day that's why i invest in
these platforms we're going to grow it
to be institutional grade and nfts will
continue to grow in value because the
institutions just like bitcoin will be
willing to trade them it's one of the
most exciting areas of crypto you are
absolutely right huge potential
um it does have huge potential but right
now
um you know after
having our own nfts and and kind of
launching it we became like number
second in the whole world to
trade in terms of volume and all of that
kind of stuff it was amazing launch we
have had we're still not sold out we
still have like uh 25 to sell out and um
what i realized was i've always been a
technical guy just numbers and you know
as a trader just look at the charts and
that's me
but here i was kind of looking at the
psychology of the whole market not just
nfd but crypto overall it's run by a lot
of greed
a lot of greed and people it's like a
mentality of get rich tomorrow or i mean
right now right so
do you think that's of going to affect
the
future in any way or that's actually the
reason it will
you know go to the moon
well there's a great analogy because
you're absolutely right it it is driven
by a lot of greed and a lot of theft and
a lot of instability right now but if
you went back to the gold rush
it was driven by greed it was driven by
people willing to take huge risk to go
and explore and find gold and become
wealthy and the people that actually got
wealthy provided the infrastructure to
them that eventually provided all the
equipment they needed to build gold
mines i'm in the camp that you need to
be in both i want to invest in nfts and
i do
but i also want to invest in all digital
infrastructure which is why i'm so
interested in the exchange licenses that
are being granted all around the world i
i'm very interested in investing in
those wherever they pop up because
they're not coming to the us anytime
soon they're starting in other
jurisdictions like canada like the uae
and other countries
and so you have to be a bit of an
explorer to understand that we're the
early phase and greed does drive a lot
of motivation
but so does theft and
most people are not willing to admit it
i am i've had a wallet that has been
hacked i've lost assets i've lost nfts
and i've learned my lesson about
security and i have a different protocol
now and it's very hard
to steal my assets now but i've had to
learn that we've got to make it easier
and so this cowboy notion of you know
the wild wild west which was there in
the great gold rush is where we're at in
nfts right now but over time
you know there's so much interest in
them whether it be art or authentication
technologies or real estate transactions
or whatever it is because it essentially
is a licensed wallet with an audit trail
which is very productive
we will continue to see advancement here
it is not going away in other words the
genie is out of the bottle and you're
just going to have to stomach the
volatility but it has huge upside
definitely definitely it's it's a
good gold rush to have definitely
yeah now um knowing that for example you
know china is banning banning crypto or
or there are other countries other
jurisdictions that are banning
cryptocurrencies
and there is also a lot of uh negative
environmental impact that is associated
with uh
mining and and
the whole
decentralized infrastructure uh with
that in mind what future for
cryptocurrencies uh can you envision or
predict uh coming into the future
this is an excellent question i mean
this this is really the question of the
day for all of us involved in
cryptocurrencies you're talking about
china banning bitcoin mining and there's
other countries including russia that
are contemplating this as well and you
are right what is driving this
motivation are concerns about esg so let
me walk you through what is happening
with the capital you know what i like to
watch is the flow of capital where is it
going because that will dictate what's
going to happen in the mining industry
so
two years ago before there was any esg
concerns on bitcoin mining when the
majority of awards were coming out of
china there was no talk about burning
coal to make electricity that was
environmentally harming bitcoin there
were lots of miners you know burning
lots of carbon whether it be gas or coal
or whatever to make coin and nobody
cared and then you saw this movement
with institutional capital it really
started with black rock the largest
institutional um you know manager in the
world that does a lot of sovereign
wealth etc
they put out a mandate saying look there
are certain uh sectors of the economy
that are
we no longer support and one of those
was anybody burning carbon
particularly burning carbon for bitcoin
mining
and so the prior to this the way that
institutions were taking an allocation
to bitcoin mining was they would buy the
stock
of a company that was trading publicly
that was a bitcoin miner or a theory
miner or a data center manager whatever
so they could get exposure to a a
marathon or a riot or whoever it was
that they decided to take a position in
as a proxy for owning bitcoin
and the way these companies were talking
about becoming carbon neutral at that
time they didn't care but as the
pressure came on for esg mandates
they started buying carbon credits
well that's not going to work because
you're going to start to see in this
year i'm speculating that these large
institutions are going to start
demanding audits carbon credit audits
and you don't want to be in a company
stock that has the risk of a carbon
audit because the truth is it's almost
virtually impossible to show and
understand the tracking error of a
carbon credit versus what you're
actually burning in carbon so all of the
money is quietly moving right now to new
mining companies most of them private
that are going to use
hydro
wind
solar and nuclear power because if you
use any of those options
for mining there is no carbon audit
there is no offset necessary you're not
burning carbon the majority or many of
the turbine driven hydro facilities
around the world in places like norway
or upstate quebec
or manitoba or british columbia or
places in the soviet with russia now
they have abundance of hydro that is not
captured
and so i'll give you an example
my one of my biggest investments right
now
is a facility being built
in norway
in a village with three thousand people
where they're partners we are using new
stacks very efficient mining equipment
we're building out now
and we are part of the community there
we have power at less than two cents a
kilowatt hour our stacks are remote
however we're using the heat that's
generated there for hydroponics and fish
rookeries and the stakeholders
of that mine are many of the villagers
that live there but here's the key
here's the key to this situation
the institutions that are backing it
and some of them are sovereign wealth
funds
ask me one thing
are the coins awarded going to stay on
the balance sheet of this company
because we'll be able to own the stock
with the proxy that we know every coin
was mined sustainably under an esg
mandate and that's how we want to own
our bitcoin if you're telling us you're
going to sell off your coin then we're
not investing we want to so you need
more capital come to us
we'll invest
but every coin awarded has to stay in
the norwegian company or whatever we're
doing the same thing in quebec we're
doing the same thing in british columbia
and other jurisdictions in texas
that's the new mentality that's what's
happening right now so a new generation
a bitcoin miner an esg compliant
non-carbon credit institutionally backed
those are the new miners and they're
going to trade at a premium and all of
the old dirty miners are going to have
to consolidate because nobody's
interested in giving them capital
anymore there's no way for them to be
clean and not be subject to carbon
audits this is going to be controversial
you're one of the first people i've been
talking to about about this because this
just emerged in the last three months
but we are
quietly taking our capital out of those
dirty miners into the new clean miners
and that's the new generation of bitcoin
miners for the next 20 30 40 50 years
that makes me so happy to hear yeah
about that like you know i always i have
that guilt inside me of that osha every
time i exchange it or trade on it is i'm
being a part of the problem but that's
just amazing to hear
and yeah my brain is overloaded with
information right now kevin how do you
keep that in your head all the time my
god
because it goes back to what we said
earlier i listen i listen two thirds of
the day i listen to the institutions
they tell me what they want and they
want esg they do not want to spend
another dime in a dirty bitcoin miner
those days are over and so this change
in capital is going to happen really
fast and there's a lot of capital
interested in clean mining if you like
that video waiting you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe